our following guest became a star for
his playing the lovable Cameron Tucker
on Modern Family but we shouldn't forget
his earlier movie roles you may remember
him from his work in such classics as
ninja cheerleaders off The Drifter and
of course knuckle sandwich
to talk about the Kansas City Chiefs
he's the next best guy please welcome
Eric Stonestreet got the Andy Reed look
going on there oh yeah look who's here
yeah you look good Eric thanks if this
is your week this is this is Kansas
City's week yeah did you pay for that
shirt did I what did you pay for that
shirt and a very popular heavyset guy
active leisure wear store yeah I don't
have a deal with them so I'm not gonna
mention them how surreal is this it's
crazy it's crazy well can I get
headphones I can't hear down there right
there yeah I'm like I'd like to hear day
there how's that I still can't hear you
okay give me some volume on these we're
good now I got somebody right there okay
Kat will help you get some volume there
cuz you're gonna want to hear right here
you're gonna want to hear this voice I
love this way yeah yeah I just need some
there we go there we go
all right now we're ready to go okay so
you grew up a Chiefs fan right yeah
diehard lifelong season ticket holder
section 130 wrote to seat six and seven
when's the last time they made you cry
the Chiefs two weeks ago you cried I
absolutely cried yeah three times three
times happy joy I cried probably as a
younger kid then I stopped crying
but they've hurt me a lot over the years
favorite chief of all time is who
favorite chief of all time that's really
hard for me Jon Walt was always my
favorite because I wanted to be
offensive lineman and he was our tackle
left tackle so John alts up there but
Christian Okoye the Nigerian nightmare
hard did not love Christian number 35
number 35
who all the offensive lineman I've
always been a no line guy but you had
them over to your house after they won
the AFC title no I didn't go over to
their house I went over to Eric Fisher's
house oh you went to it yeah I went to
Eric Fisher and Anthony Sherman's house
and I showed him our video okay but do
they understand that that was from the
previous year that was not from the
previous year well I picked that I
picked the Chiefs to win the Superbowl
on this show this after I was on then
well that was in May okay well this is
the start of the year the start of the
season I said the Chiefs are going to
win the Super Bowl and beat the Eagles
well that was my prediction okay I mean
we have time we can we can we can
document this I was on the show you must
have really listened to what I had to
say and then pick the Chiefs no that's
not true at all I didn't listen I I
realized that I owe you a bet from a bet
I owe you dinner right but I'm ready to
sweeten the deal
okay I got a trigger grill over there oh
my that I want to send to you oh and
this way after the Chiefs win the Super
Bowl you are going to be for the Kansas
City Chiefs offensive lineman so free of
charge and we're gonna send some meat
there oh so nice that's nice we'll do
that absolutely I accept that and then
we'll also do the dinner where we go to
dinner and you have to sit across from
the offensive line and and talk about
how we went further than the San Diego
Chargers and the LA Chargers and the LA
Times but I pick the Chiefs to win the
soup wages I don't understand I'm not
gonna argue with you this your show in
May I picked the Chargers when was I
show we have in May I'm getting angry
in May of 2019 you were on the show yeah
I made my prediction in September that
they would go we were just messing with
me yes I was you were just trying to
rile me yes I was ok well now this is
different this is just hurtful now this
means oh don't go Cameron on me do you
ever do that character with your
girlfriend no but when you walk down the
street like do people want you to be
that character Oh desperately would
rather me be that guy what are they what
do they ask you uh are you are you not
feeling well I get a lot you know
because my personality is not as
vivacious as cam yeah so they'll say
that but you know they they ask me to oh
I get this a lot can you yell Stella
they'll say can you just yell Stella and
all say things like that where's Lilly
is a popular question where's Lilly
like chained in a closet at twentieth
century-fox we keep her right there how
do you explain the success of Modern
Family uh family families Universal the
universal thing is is that we're all
come from some sort of family and we all
have crazy people in that family that do
outrageous things from time to time that
we don't think other people do and
that's what Modern Family writer the
rebound and family writers have done
such a good job of doing is just
reflecting back to people that you know
these things happen everywhere have you
ever gotten a script and go oh no yeah
yeah and then it works oh and then
you're like that's why I'm just doing
how many shows you have left two more we
have to tape two more I leave here after
hopefully a Super Bowl victory go back
to Los Angeles do a table read on
Wednesday and then we start shooting on
the 10th and we'll be done by the 21st
and you don't die in the end do you
I can't say no I don't you don't you
know I know of CAM for sure doesn't and
we hope I don't what what kind of seats
you got for Sunday pretty good seats
yeah pretty who hooked you up I can't
think of his first name get something
Goodell oh that's nice yeah no I'll tell
you the story five years ago I posted on
my Instagram yesterday that Jimmy Kimmel
asked me if I was going to the Super
Bowl and I said I will never go to the
Super Bowl unless the Kansas City Chiefs
are in the Super Bowl and unrelated to
that or at least Roger swears and Jane
who's a wonderful wonderful woman
they're great people says that this is
was not related to this he called me two
days later and said we asked my
daughter's who they would like to invite
to the Super Bowl and they chose cam for
Modern Family would you like to come to
the Super Ball and I said no not until
the Chiefs are in it and he said all
right if you want to wait that long
that's fair enough
oh and I was like oh and so this is my
rain check
so Roger has made good on his promise to
take me to the Super Bowl when the
Kansas City Chiefs were in it
that's awesome are you nervous sorry I'm
nervous okay I'm nervous aren't you guys
nervous yeah but here's the thing
here's what I want to tell you Kansas
City fans remember all those times John
Elway marched down the field and beat us
in the last two minutes remember all the
times the Peyton Manning did it Tom
Brady did it guess what guess who we
have now we have
[Applause]
not this time though not this time
you got a chance to bang the drum at the
Chiefs game yeah yeah it's awesome yeah
it's great it's great tradition their
arrowheads great you talk to people that
go all tall stadiums and I know
everybody's a fan and and I'm a fan
first so I love that you support the
team you support the city you're from
that's what being a fan is to me having
said all that come to Arrowhead sometime
when your team visits our Arrowhead and
just come to a game and you tell me
that's not one of the best stadiums and
best atmospheres and best places in the
NFL seaton you went to a game there in
Kansas City I did yeah yeah I went
tailgate and there's it's amazing
everybody there it's got like a bus
that's been modified in there there's
this sort of smoky haze that just hangs
over the parking lot from the all the
tail in the barbecue it's amazing so I
went to every game this season I wasn't
gonna miss the season because unlike you
I picked the Chiefs to go to the Super
Bowl I'll just get you know III wasn't
gonna miss the game so I went to every
game and rollin in on Sunday mornings
especially in the cold there's no better
smell than cold-weather charcoal smell
hmm I want a Cologne that is cold
weather charcoal smelled like it yeah
like and you roll into Arrowhead that's
what you smell and everybody's like I'm
like we're here baby so you would you
would go no matter where they were and
then go back and get out to be at work
on Monday only home games I only went to
okay
yeah and then you'd come back for Monday
mm-hmm read through or whatever you have
work we do we read throughs on Wednesday
so I would fly home on Sunday nights or
early Monday mornings you met moms oh
yeah I met him
yeah he's a nice guy great kid yeah I
know that if you posted on Instagram
about how Coby went to the set of Modern
Family watch you that was like 2014 2013
yeah it was in 13 what was that like
amazing you know what people need to
know about Kobe and and I and I've read
a lot of stories that are similar to
mine just that he he seeked excellence
and he seeked you know to learn in all
avenues of his life and that's why he
came to Modern Family he just he said he
woke up that morning and he wanted to
watch something funny
and you know the average person to be
like well I'm gonna turn on the TV but
Kobe's like no I want to go watch the my
favorite TV show shoot the TV show so he
came and hang out watched his block and
rehearsed scenes and I asked him you
know what he thought of that and he's
like you know it's kind of like setting
an offense you know I like that
everybody knows where they have to be in
counterpoint point counterpoint and all
this and then earlier then that year I
had seen him somewhere and I must have
said hey come by the set sometime and
everybody would love to have you over
and so when he was leaving that day I
asked him you know what made you decide
to come over today and he said that you
know I wanted to do something funny and
he's plus man you told me to stop by
sometime because of me like man I just
love the show he was an awesome guy make
you nervous while you're shooting know
because his his generosity with everyone
around I mean he he knows when he knew
when he would go someplace what it was
like and he came and took pictures with
everybody and hung out and you know if I
was playing basketball around he'll be
nervous but doing what I am good at I
was confident in my abilities you're
gonna bet on the game no I don't bet I
don't bet was that disappoint you then
no just surprised I just seemed angry no
no not angry I think you manufactured
this beef there's no real beef here
right over my shoulder on that trigger
grills there's proof of our beef Dan we
have proof of our beef whatever whatever
bet we have I hope you win I you need it
more than I do oh you son
most horrible you need argument point
you really know the city deserves it
[Music]
l'amour hunt and the family of Lamar
Hunt deserve it I don't need anything I
need my dinner with my offensive line
and you and then staring at me that's
what I need but look modern families
being canceled every would you know me
on the street if we saw each other
outside of the street would you be like
I wouldn't acknowledge you thought I
would know it was you yeah that's what I
figured I knew you were that guy hey hey
would you say Stella yeah that's what I
would say hey would you say so I
wouldn't call you Erica Chloe Cameron
you would yeah I mean I learned early on
that O'Neill taught me that he was like
look everybody's gonna call you by your
character's name and you got to get over
carrying about yeah yeah he said you
keep track other ways they know you as
cam just accept it people still will see
me and be like hey I got a question for
you what's it like working with Al Bundy
[Laughter]
what was the one that somebody said Oh
somebody asked me I got a Lyndsey's
proof that this happened my girlfriend's
over there and she's proof had happen
and I think I'm gonna get it right but
they were like Ted Bundy on see that
would be an interesting plot twist Ted
Bundy's down there what are you guys
doing the rest of the day hey congrats
no I'm gonna move out next
he's a show over yeah oh yeah we're
getting cancelled Hey just like Modern
Family
we did 11 seasons I know years have you
done here I've been 13 years and then
you were on ESPN oh yeah and all those
years 18 years there all it proves is
you're old
I'm rooting for you you are cuz you yeah
you need something in your life oh you
need such the alpha argument he's trying
to do it guys no I'm right there with
you we are Chiefs are going to win the
Super Bowl our Chiefs are gonna win the
[ __ ] there you go but you know what the
49ers are a great team and what I love
about this Super Bowl is that it's not a
lot of trash talk like we're you know
it's it's about football and it's about
two good teams lining up playing the
game and I think it's gonna be a close
game I think it's gonna be a
high-scoring game but I think Andy Reed
and somebody you know somebody else is
gonna make a big play on the Chiefs but
I think Andy Reed is the x-factor I
think the coaching is gonna is gonna I
don't need you breaking down the game I
mean just take the win and go home I
don't need it broken down yes they do
no they don't yes no they don't whatever
all right here you got your headphones
on this is me after three minutes this
is me
picking the Chiefs to win the Super Bowl
I need dates and times I am going to
take
the Kansas City yeah to win the
Superbowl okay where's this monitor it's
right there it's in your ear and you
could have recorded that three minutes
before I came out here with the timpani
drum I don't know we have beef can you
guys confirm that I picked Kansas City
Chiefs whatever you say boss
whatever you say boss that's the world
you want to live in with a bunch of yes
men I don't think so yes mclubbe I can
confirm it was 2018 but that's details
right no I'm kidding yes of course now
since a temp entombed yeah there that
was not a failure right there you're
great on family matters what Todd why do
you want I'm just glad I didn't say okay
good none of you are gonna stick up for
me
what do you want I'm paying off a bad I
will say there is a little recording
studio in the back so you may be onto
something away you can the few little
podcast and record things right before
the show starts though he's Eric
Stonestreet and two more episodes and
he's a big Chiefs fan and we're sending
him a Trager grill I just um
when we go into commercial break you
give me your address and I'm sending you
a Trager grill all right yeah you give
me your address and I'm gonna send you a
pile of steaming flaming you-know-what
on your front what are you doing it's a
Kansas City trick in it you go out there
stomp it out you're like thank you Eric
I love you Dan thank you I can tell
that's Eric Stonestreet of the soon to
be canceled
[Applause]
[Music]
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]